There are three main
communication skills
that students will learn
through the process of doing
lab work in Junior Lab.
The main one is doing
oral presentations,
the type of talks that somebody
would give at a conference.
A typically 12 to 15 minute
type, professional level
talk, with some sort of--
usually with electronic slides,
like a PowerPoint or
something like that.
The second one is
we write papers.
They write papers in the
style of the Physical Review
Letters, which is more or less
the most important journal
in physics.
It's a very constrained format.
It's a maximum of four
pages, two columns.
It's written for a generalist
physicist audience.
So it's somebody who's
your professional peer,
but may not be working in
your direct research field.
So writing a Physical
Review letter is a--
it's a challenge both as a
writer and as a researcher.
So the students get
a lot of practice
in that over the course of 8.13.
The third mode of
communication which students
will get a lot of practice
with in the course of doing
lab work in 8.13 is just
communicating with a peer.
Working as part of
a team, learning
to listen to what
your partner is saying
and understand what
they mean by that.
Learning to be patient
with people, learning
to explain yourself in
live time with somebody
that you're trying to cooperate
with to achieve some goal.
Having to make decisions.
Having to negotiate
decisions, when
you think the most important
measurement to make is this
and your partner thinks the
important measurement to make
is that.
Working through those sort
of interpersonal types
of communication.
They get lots of
practice for that,
whether they like it or not.